how's it going bros my name is Pam
welcome to there are some questions in
life that we all ask ourselves everyday
who is your YouTube girlfriend is not
one of them but that's what we're gonna
find out anyway I found this quiz that
will tell me it's obviously gonna be
mindset but let's do it anyway
because it could be fun Jesus Christ
what do you do on Sundays well
I sure as hell don't go on picnics I
sure as hell don't go to gym I'd rather
kill myself than go to Starbucks so PJ
day yeah
if you had to spend $500 on your
girlfriend haha [ __ ] please like I
gotta spend five I'll keep it duh how
old you want her to be around my age
which or the following following accent
do you like the best
I don't mind you don't mind one what it
okay I don't mind
well oh great
I got Marcia my lovely girlfriend
Marcia I'm so glad I got my yes my
youtube girlfriend so happy it says I
got equal amount of answers for all
these other youtubers why do they pick
though I mean Marcia okay this was a
[ __ ] test let's try another one now this
is a good test which narrowed a girl
would date you mature pictures I was
wondering if you like a drink
gives wine menu
so go for some Jack Daniels thank you
very much what kind of girl do you
prefer smart and useful girl but
wouldn't get in my way
unless I told her to help where are they
mature [ __ ] images
I got my CI all right let's try this
again
don't worry brass what youtuber would
you date hi everyone sorry if this sucks
the first one is not even a question
hey and it's fine sure no problem love
whatever yeah can we get on with it
it's no issue I can't even begin to
describe all the issues I have with this
[ __ ] yeah can we get on with it
[ __ ] you know okay so what's your
favorite color hides behind Dan what do
you spend your time doing being a
sarcastic [ __ ] who do I want beauty Pat
goodbye
whatever what the [ __ ] is this
you're not Marcia I mean oh look I got
my tea I asked my YouTube girlfriend
again it's [ __ ] [ __ ] how do I change
the results
you shivered as you walked along the
sidewalk in Sweden why your brother
moved here you had no idea you were
wearing this
[Music]
I look [ __ ] Titus [ __ ] those pants
man where can i buy those they're sold
out alright press let me know if you
want me to do more quizzes I am I'll I
sincerely doubt it after this [ __ ] but
go ahead and even like it makes me feel
better about this myself I look at the
video and I'll be like holy [ __ ] that
video was actually popular for once
maybe I shouldn't kill myself after all
but anyway I hope you guys enjoyed thank
you so much for watching and as always
stay awesome bros
[Applause]
[Music]